[Music]
and we are live
our Lord podcast Lords of gaming dotnet
lore Candido here Lord elder here with a
legend in the round
we have Lord Jerome ASF how you doing
sir good very good thanks for having me
on the show absolute pleasure to have
you guys so let's get right into it as
far as YouTube your journey as a content
creator you know let's start from the
very beginning for so what kind of got
you would inspires you to create your
challenge just get into youtube gaming
sure so I started my original channel
back in March of 2008 so I've been doing
it now for about 12 years and at the
time I was 14 years old and best way to
put it I was bored and I tried this new
thing called YouTube you know is fairly
new at the time in 2008 I ended up
falling in love with it the problem is
my friends didn't share the same passion
for it so I was like well what can i
film by myself and then I was like well
I love video games so I started filling
myself playing video games and then it
just kind of spurred from there so just
out of a passion for video making really
awesome awesome so initial video games
was the foundation that's what kind of
got you there so what was some of the
early videos that should go or early
games that you kind of were only a
channel into gravitated towards so at
the time I really gravitated towards
it's not the most popular games but
they're games that I enjoyed playing
which was very important for me
throughout my career was always focusing
on the games that I liked nice but that
would be Spore was the first one which
was an amazing game yeah Spore I also
did a couple runescape videos Halo 3
unfortunately there's more like emphasis
on Cod at the time in the community but
I loved halo that was my like my bread
and butter
so halo a bunch and a little bit of Cod
here and there right nice so I was gonna
ask a lot of what I do is which a
channel have huge minecraft yes huge my
before that as well influences well
unfortunately I tried for night for a
while I kind of fell
love with it because he got too
competitive my channel is unlike most
gaming channels less emphasized on the
on the I guess the how do I say hardcore
gaming and more so just on a group of
friends having a fun time that's really
where the emphasis lies so for that I
kind of lost the passion to do fortnight
5 so we came back to minecraft though so
what the what drove you to say okay you
know what this game and I don't want to
focus what I want to create content for
it like what's that passion about sure
so the reason I started doing minecraft
is simply because it's endless I mean
it's a sandbox game and I couldn't even
begin to estimate how much time it would
take you from start to finish to do
every single thing there is to do I mean
there are tens of thousands of mods out
there there's hundreds of thousands of
maps there's tens of thousands of
servers there's all sorts of different
ways you can play the game I genuinely
think if you took someone from birth
throughout the entirety of their life
they could not play everything in the
game
so for me I loved that it was what you
made of it and that there was no end to
it that's pretty cool yeah when like so
you saying that you you started really
really young in the in the YouTube game
if you will so when you start it was a
long time ago I assume um when you
started thinking about like doing that
it was just like basically they can
record it just published it or did you
kind of like take the time to end it or
did you kind of take some time over time
how did you kind of like develop your
you know your technique and on your
video making yeah so when I initially
initially started out there was very
limited editing a lot of it was just
kind of off the cuff gameplay that me
and my friends would hop in and just act
like completed and then once we started
to like get a little bit of a following
I was like okay maybe we can't be you
know you can get away with it at first
but you got a mission transition so I
started doing a little bit the editing
myself I was not very good at it I still
am not to this day but luckily enough
nowadays I have an editor that works
full-time and just you know makes our
content look as amazing as it does what
was that moment with mom that you said
the conversation yes so I was absolutely
stunned I mean I first told my mom I
thought I was gonna go horribly but I'll
never forget where I was I literally can
tell you right now I was on college
Avenue which is Street Jersey New
Brunswick for Rutgers so that faster I
was going to school at the time I was on
the street just pacing back and forth
and finally it's like you know that's it
I'm gonna call her call my mom up and
there's a brief pause you know Mike oh
gosh she's gonna kill him and then she
just goes no that makes a lot of sense
you seem really stressed lately so then
you know that's okay you know I could
tell us is really working for you and
and and you know so you should do that I
you know I don't like seeing you so
stressed and I was like really and she
goes yeah she's like but if it fails
you're going back okay like I said see
you next Anna what advice would you give
to new content creators try to get this
stake in the game trying to figure out
this YouTube thing and find themselves
so the best advice that I could give is
that there is no one formula to success
on YouTube what really matters is paving
your own way and making it unique and
funny and and or entertaining or
whatever it is that you're going for so
the best way that I would say to do that
is pick something you love and just roll
with it because if you're trying to
emulate someone else's formula you're
not gonna stand out you're doing exactly
what other people are doing you need
something that makes you different and
the best way to do that is literally be
yourself if this is what you like doing
the same way that I liked playing spore
I like playing runescape I like playing
Halo 3 although they weren't the most
popular games on YouTube and that's just
what I did
so you you said that you your team you
know you guys are working six days a
week how do you prevent burnout because
that's that's because that's extremely
extremely heavy I thought like what we
do doing our full-time jobs and doing
this nighttime stuff
it seems very pressure for how do you
guys you know you know what's that
problem for us really we just you know I
guess the best way to put it is being
we're enjoying what we're doing it it
makes it a little bit harder to get that
burnout you know like it's kind of hard
when you're playing games are you enjoy
all day like you know where we hopped
from playing arc and recording a couple
videos then we'll go over to minecraft
like it's like these are fun games like
it's actually what I would have done
that because that's a great point
because some people certain content
creators actually take the opposite
approach they're like oh this is
not the popular game I gotta go with
trends going and I gotta follow because
all the gamers are playing this I need
to play this and sometimes they ended up
being miserable because it's something
they don't enjoy playing but you took
the opposite approach to said look I'm
gonna play what I like playing and dance
even if it's not poppin even if it's not
popular and stick with it that's pretty
awesome pretty unique exactly yeah and
and that's the thing too is people like
minecraft for instance people always
assume minecraft always been on top and
it really hasn't when I started filming
it back in 2011 it was on people's
radars but it certainly wasn't the
number one game and then over time as
well I continued to do that through 2011
all the way onto 2020 now and believe me
along the way there were times when
minecraft wasn't that popular questions
good thanks ok we have an absolute
legend in the realm Lords roam ASF
breaking it down the journey everything
what else do you like to tell your fans
that people who follow your content in
terms of people who follow my content of
my fans I just want to say thank you
thanks so much for letting me do what I
love for a career and and just it brings
me real happiness like it really does
you know at the end of the day I'll
never forget what my dad said where he
said you know he's like Jerome at the
end of the day your job you wake up and
you get to make people happy for a
living that's you can't ask for more
than that and I hold that saying very
near and dear to my heart when my dad
said so I'm just very grateful to them
absolutely awesome large role but after
the pleasure to have you in the room I
love Pacha's Lords of gaming dotnet we
are signing out figs
[Music]